now the scottish first minister nicola
sturgeon has promised to set out her
plans for a second referendum on
independence
setting up the future of the union as
one of the major political issues coming
down the track
the labour party could have a critical
role in shaping scotland's future
but it's been a decade of decline for
the party north of the border
back in 2010 they were the dominant
force in scotland winning 41 of the 59
seats but
fast forward to last december and they'd
crumbled winning just one seat in a
nation
now dominated by the snp in hopes for
improvement of slim
this poll from last month shows them in
third place on just 14
behind the conservatives and miles
behind nicholas sturgeon's party
because of that pressure is growing on
the scottish labour leader richard
leonard four msps and a handful of peers
have now openly called for him to resign
but he's vowed to fight on and he joined
us now from paisley thank you very much
for being with us
so some of your colleagues as we
mentioned are calling for you to resign
are you going to
uh no i'm not um and i think those
people that have been calling this week
for me to step down
have underestimated both my resolve but
also the mandate that i got from the
scottish labor party
look sophie um prior to my election as
the leader just under three years ago
we'd had five leaders of the scottish
labour party in six years
and so the mandate that i was given by
the members when they
convincingly elected me to be the leader
was to campaign on a radical agenda
but it was also to be the leader of the
scottish labor party going into the may
2021 scottish parliament elections
at the same time though surely you can
understand why people are concerned
labour's gone from being the dominant
party in scotland to
almost an irrelevance you won just one
westminster sea in december
you're third in the polls you can see
why people are worried
yeah and this has been part of a
long-term trend but look
the situation that we now face
economically and health-wise because of
the pandemic
has really changed the dial of politics
and i think
you know the people i'm speaking to are
having sleepless nights because they
don't know
when the job retention scheme comes to
an end at the end of october
whether it december they'll have a job
or not
so we are expecting a huge spike in
unemployment
we know that there will be enormous
pressures on the national health service
for example we know that there has been
a crisis
in social care all of these things i
think are moving people's focus on from
some of these constitutional questions
uh brexit dominated last december's
election not only
in the rest of the uk but in scotland as
well i think that there is
um a new climber of politics in scotland
which will allow us to start to get our
messages across
about the need for urgent action to
tackle the job crisis
urgent action to make sure we've got
investment in public services
like the health service and and i'm sure
that um
when we get to the elections next may
people will understand
what we which is that the soulful
of the next scottish parliament and the
next scottish government
has got to be on tackling these big
questions climate change so if that's
all if that's all the case then if
that's all the case then why are people
calling for you to go are they just a
bunch of dis
effective blair rights well look there
are some people who
uh really never accepted the result when
i was elected
back um there are um
you know i i think there are some people
who misread uh
the mood of the party membership um
i was given a strong mandate when i was
elected and i've had a huge
number of messages of support from right
across the labor party and
you know people who would consider
themselves to be on the centre or the
right of the labour party and
i would consider myself to be here on
the left of the labour party
so right across the board uh there has
been a a a massive
um i think strong message of support for
me and for my leadership
and you know at a very point when the
country's in a crisis
eight months out from an election uh the
last thing that people want to see is
the labour party turning itself
in on in on itself and and look others
might
say that others might say with respect
though that the last thing the labour
party needs is a scottish
leader who is failing to get more than
14
in the polls and is only winning one
westminster sea in december
well when i inherited the party it was
in third place
it still is in third place but we've got
a you know we've got an opportunity here
to start to make real progress and rest
assured that i will be campaigning for
every
seat as we go into the um elections next
year
i will be touring the country over the
next few months speaking to people
about the jobs crisis about what we need
to do to uh
to solve the unemployment spike that we
are likely to face
and that's about job retention it's
about job guarantees it's about job
creation
you're obviously keen to talk about
you're obviously keen to talk about
jobs and unemployment in scotland but of
course another big feature of how people
vote
is the question of independence so i
just want to really clarify your view
are you completely opposed to the idea
of independence
even if the snp win a majority in the
scottish parliament elections next year
which many people would see as a mandate
for another
referendum well two things sophie first
of all
i do not believe it serves the best
interests of the people of scotland to
set up a separate scottish state i think
you know the valleys of cooperation
solidarity working together
are ones that drive my politics but
secondly
we've said that going into the elections
next year because of the scale of the
crisis economic
uh the crisis in public services uh the
need for investment
the the priority for the next scottish
parliament and the next scottish
government
should not be around constitutional
questions it needs to be about solving
those social and economic questions
and that's why i've said that we will go
into those elections next year
opposed to a second independence
referendum of course we want reform and
modernization of the british state it is
too centralized and with brexit there
are challenges there about how we can
get
more co-determination between a
government a welsh government
a northern irish executive and the uk
government there needs to be a
greater parity of esteem between those
parts of the uk and
and greater decentralization so just
just be crystal clear i think that the
way forward is for the creation of a
separate scottish state because i do not
just to be crystal clear then even if
the snp win majority
uh in the elections will you be opposed
to a second referendum
on independence in all circumstances
well sophie you'll forgive me but eight
months out from an election i'm not
going to concede
uh the result to the snp you know there
is a there is a there will be a
reckoning
for the smp's record both in the
handling of covid
and over the last it said that education
was going to be its top priority and
actually
um attainment in education the gap
between the poorest
areas and the better off areas that gap
is widening so
so on their record uh whether it's an
education the delivery of public
services on jobs uh on green jobs
uh whether it's their record in their
handling of the pandemic and the
and the scandal of what's happened in
scotland's residential care homes
these are big questions which the smp
will be will be called to account for
and i think when that happens people
will understand
that there are alternatives that there
were alternatives and in the future
there is an alternative way that
scotland could be governed
okay thank you very much for being on
the program this morning richard
leonard there the leader of the labour
party in scotland